113 questions about evolution with John
Perry hanging out with cousin Paige
Malibu Edition how old should a person
be before learning about evolution
this is kind of a question about
parenting so different parents would
have different opinions about this but
evolution is about reproduction and
death really
you know there's survival and
reproduction and so for someone to
really understand really dig into
evolution and understand it inside and
out they need to understand they need to
be old enough to understand what
reproduction is and what death is so for
different kids that come at different
times
I suppose you know I'd say maybe a lot
of kids could learn about that when
they're about eight between eight to ten
but there are simpler parts of evolution
more friendlier parts I guess you could
say that kids are ready to learn when a
lot younger like kids can learn that
they're related to other animals you
know there's a there's a really good
book called grandmother fish which is
for little kids and it just talks about
the relationship that we have between us
and other animals and you could you can
start teaching kids that when they're
you know as soon as they can talk and
point at animals as soon as they notice
that animals are different than them you
can point out similarities and
differences for me when I was a little
cats probably five when I noticed that I
was the same as my dog we had the same
bones and I noticed that his his back
legs it looked like he had backwards
knees but I realized it's actually his
heel bone was a little backwards neat
looking thing and I got super excited
and told my parents all about it and
kids can start to learn that they're
related to plants and animals and all
other organisms as soon as they start to
learn about organisms but I would say
before you really really dig into the
details of evolution you need to
understand what reproduction is and what
death is
you